So at this philosophical level there's
one last thing I want to talk about.
We just talked about
evaluating a policy but
remember in the reinforcement
learning setting,
the policy is what gets output as
a result of the learning process.
So what if we want to actually
evaluate the learner?
How good is this learner?
Can you think of some ways that we might
be able to decide how good a learner is?
>> Sure.
It's as good as its policy.
>> So that seems like a good idea.
That a good learner is one that
returns a good policy, sure.
What if we have two learners that return
the same policy say the optimal policy?
>> Oh okay, well I can think
of two responses to that.
One is who cares they're
both the same and
the only thing that matters is how good
the policy is that you come up with.
Or I could come up with
another answer which would be,
I will take the one that
does it more quickly.
>> Quickly in terms of what?
>> Let's say time.
>> [LAUGH] I think that's
what quickly means.
Yes, but time of what?
There's lots of different
kinds of time that matter.
So one in particular
is computation time?
>> Yeah, wall clock time.
>> And that seems like an important one,
right?
We want one that's going to
be more efficient in terms of
the computations that it does in
the process of learning the policy.
But there's another kind of time
that actually matters a lot
in the reinforcement learning settings,
so I think it's worth mentioning.
>> Okay.
>> So the other kind of complexity that
turns out to be really important in this
learning setting is
experience complexity.
Do you have a sense of
what that might mean?
>> How complex your experiences are?
>> I'm going to say no.
>> Oh, okay, I get it.
So computational complexity is sort of
how much computational energy you have
to put into it.
So this would be how much experience
you have to have in order to learn.
So it's the amount of
data that you need.
>> Yeah, so if two different learners
can learn the same optimal policy, but
one only requires a couple interactions
with the environment to do it, and
the other one requires a billion,
the one that has the lower experience
complexity should be preferred.
Though of course there's trade-offs.
If to do that it actually
has to compute for
2 billion years then that seems
maybe not so good either.
So there can be little trade-offs
between how much time that the learner
takes in terms of interactions with the
environment and how much time that it
takes in terms of the computations
that it does between interactions.
>> Hm.
Do you know what this reminds me of?
It reminds me of two things.
It reminds me of MIMIC
because that was the exact
trade-off that we were making then.
>> Oh, yeah.
Okay, sure.
>> And the other thing is that it
reminds me of the theory lecture that
we did in the Intro to
Machine Learning class
where we talked about sample complexity.
>> Yes, that's good.
That probably is a better name
than experience complexity.
Let's call it sample complexity.
Yeah, because it really is about
the data that's necessary to achieve
the learning ends.
>> All right.
>> All right, so this kind of sets the
stage for what reinforcement learning
is, and how compare different
learners to each other, and
how we compare the outputs of
those learners to each other.
What we're going to dive into
next is actual algorithms for
doing this kind of learning.
>> Yeah that sounds good,
can I ask you a question?
>> Sure.
>> So,
why aren't we talking about space?
>> Ooh, so space complexity.
So that's a good question.
In computer science,
usually computation time and
computation space are the two dimensions
along which we evaluate algorithms.
Here I guess we could do that too.
You could talk about the space
that an algorithm uses.
Our learning algorithm uses, but
it's generally not that interesting.
Generally we don't, we're not
limited by the space complexity.
We usually run into issues more
quickly on the computational or
the sample complexity side.